[Applaudissements]
la pub Benetton est-elle de la pub du
journalisme de l'art ou un scandale pour
le savoir j'accueille Olivia loto
scanner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir alors ton père était photographe
à la coriane était la Sierra il était
reporteur photographe et tu as eu un
jour un appareil photo tu quel âge tu
avais quand tu as eu ça et tu faisais
déjà des photos avant tu faisais déjà
des photos avant mais ça c'était mon
premier appareil à moi personnellement
ensuite tu es devenu photographe de mode
donc je travaille pour elle pour Harper
pour Vogue je fais des campagnes de pub
pour 6 routchi esprit Valentino et la
première fois où le grand public a
entendu parler de toi c'est la campagne
des jeans Jésus alors c'était quoi
c'était un scandale terrible à l'époque
c'était en 65
un très beau joli derrière une très
jolie fille
du fond du mandolino
et les slogans c'était qui même me suit
et bien sûr les Vatican à s'insurer tout
de suite ça cette campagne c'est un
petit campagne d'ailleurs le producteur
de jeunes c'est un ami à moi c'était moi
qui avait dit on va choisir le nom Jésus
parce qu'on avait choisi ce nom pendant
les 10 classes superstars à New York
c'était moment un peu spécial
et bien sûr le Vatican c'était con mais
pas olini sur les colliers de la serre
vous savez qui c'est pas joli c'était me
défendait alors c'est sorti la première
vraiment
contestation sur une photo de publicités
c'était la première fois où on discutait
vraiment publiquement des limites de la
pub pas la limite mais la signification
de la pub c'était pas on parlait déjà
plus de la si on vendait on va dépendre
mais on parlait de l'image en soi et
alors après il y a eu les fameuses
campagnes Benetton que tout le monde
connaît
tu as commencé par faire des photos pour
Benetton et puis après tu t'es contenté
d'en choisir sur de prendre des images
d'actualité et des utiliser pour la pour
la publicité de Benetton parmi les plus
connus il y a eu le fémur humain c'est à
dire c'est un soldat noir qui tenait
comme ça dans son dos un fémur humain et
on t'a accusé enfin on a accusé les gens
de Benetton de faire référence au
cannibalisme
supposé des Noirs aujourd'hui et toi tu
as répondu qu'en fait c'était simplement
un noir qui singer
un soldat britannique en fait pas tout à
fait j'ai choisi cette photo parce que
c'était assez emblématique de certains
violences qu'on a mené dans ces pays la
réaction de la violence dans ces pays
d'ailleurs dans ces moments en ce moment
Rwanda ça passe des choses qui sont
assez
l'accouchement aussi qui a fait un gros
scandale
tu dis que par exemple les anglais l'ont
refusé parce qu'ils n'aiment pas les
enfants c'est vrai que c'était refusé en
Angleterre cette campagne
et le bébé blanc et la maman noire aussi
qui a été très attaquée parce que
c'était censé faire référence à l'époque
où les nounous étaient noirs
un japonais a fini par dire que le lait
de toutes les mères était blanc ça a
sauvé l'affaire et une campagne qui a
fait grand scandale en France c'était la
bonne sœur qui qui embrassait le prêtre
ah si quand même
quelque chose qui est pas banale il y a
toujours des des gens qui sont
contraires mais d'ailleurs j'ai tout ça
très intéressant mais la photo par
exemple du du juif traditionnel avec le
Palestinien au début il y avait quand
même un des dollars avant de mettre le
globe terrestre je vais quand même des
dollars qui sortaient de la poche
il y a une communauté française qui a
pas voulu ça et on m'a fait enlever les
affiches qu'on avait fait il agonie du
sida David Kirby qui a fait beaucoup
beaucoup de scandales qui a provoqué un
tollé général et puis récemment
l'histoire de HIV positif donc
séropositif HIV tatoué sur les gens
est-ce que tu crois pas que là ça
commence à devenir un peu trop parce que
c'est pas l'idée de finalement de
marquer les marquer les idéesens
quand tu vois par exemple qu'un sida
achète une page de libération pour
répondre à cette campagne HIV positive
tatoué sur les gens il achète une page
dans Libération il dit pendant l'agonie
la vente continue c'est-à-dire qu'il
dépense 80 000 francs pour acheter cette
on pourrait dire ça aussi à Citroën
Peugeot Renault et Fiat pendant la
journée des gens c'était sur l'autoroute
la vente continue alors à l'époque quand
même on voyait dans dans le métro à
l'époque de cette campagne HIV positive
luciano Benetton ton sida c'est le fric
le sida a beaucoup en meurt Benetton
fait son beurre c'est quand même pas
très positif pour la marque quand même
ça quand on voit écrit ça dans le métro
quand les gens vont jusqu'à
une grande personne tâche de gens
pensent que la publicité c'est stupide
c'est idiote et à la fin ils sont des
fondamentalistes si la publicité passe
stupide il se fâche alors si on propose
quelque chose d'autre dans la
communication publicitaire il y a des
gens qui se fâchent mais il y a écrit
nulle part que la publicité doit être
stupide il y a que Monsieur Séguéla qui
dit ça
mais c'est pas une règle il y a aussi
cette double page avec tous les tous les
sexes à laquelle plein de sexe comme ça
en double passent dans Libération à
laquelle éminence a répondu 48 heures
plus tard avec des sexes habillés et
dernièrement cette campagne avec les
vêtements du soldat bosniaque tombe
quand même fâché un petit peu avec le
groupe Benetton puisque
Aldo palmeric et le directeur général a
dit par son niveau culturel
Toscani est tout simplement un sous
homme
toi tu as répondu c'est plus facile de
trouver un directeur général qu'un bon
créatif
comment ça va alors aujourd'hui avec
Benetton avec Beneton très bien ouais
bien sûr c'est bien je suis encore là il
m'a demandé de rester il t'a demandé de
continuer à faire la publicité de ses
vêtements oui parce que les actions de
la marque quand ils ont su Wall Street
et j'allais partir sont baissés de 9%
alors quand tu dis je me fous que les
gens rentrent dans un magasin pour
acheter un pull Benetton
ça doit pas faire monter les actions
quand même si
mais c'est pas mon problème faire des
ventes c'est pas on me demande pas
devant on me demande de faire des images
je crois que les gens qui vendent les
gens qui font les images de faire des
images
[Musique]
tu penses que ça vante les images non
non peut-être non
peut-être non mais je crois que dans ce
moment de crise la marque marche très
bien
je sais pas comment se fait mais je
crois que le public est beaucoup moins
imbécile que les publicitaires pensent
oui est-ce que tu crois au fond que ta
pub fait de la pub à Benetton
c'est sûrement une dans les adjoint
c'est
Benetton est devenu un des cinq marques
plus connu au monde à cause de quoi à la
fin des produits
surtout pareil des marques différents
produits toutes les mêmes choses la
différence aujourd'hui c'est dans
l'image on se rappelle des images c'est
ça qui capitalise un nom les produits on
les on les redessine à chaque fois on
fait une nouvelle collection on se
rappelle pas d'un produit vraiment on se
rappelle d'une image as-tu détestes les
publicitaires tu as dit j'emmerde tous
les publicitaires il ne produisent que
du mensonge avec des femmes trop belles
des hommes trop musclés et des voitures
sans embrayage
il va avoir un procès de Nuremberg aux
publicitaires un jour c'est eux qui font
la mauvaise société je trouve qu'ils
font ils font des mensonges il étudie
les mensonges tout le temps ils font
devenir les filles nordiques
et en plus il y a des
collaborationsnistes de la part de
Chanel à utiliser une fille qui ressort
au troisième rail mais c'est incroyable
ça Claudia
pour donner au fond les complexes d'être
moche
mais je trouve ça abominable
parfois tu prétends faire du journalisme
tu dis je fais de l'info je fais de
l'information en achetant de l'espace
publicitaire alors ça c'est pas par
rapport à ton père comme ça qui lui
mettait ses petites photos dans un
collier à la des lacets là toi tu les
mets sur les murs c'est quoi c'est une
revanche ça de je crois qu'il y a des
nouveaux façons de médias il y a aucun
journaliste qui a la chance d'avoir la
même photo dans tous les journaux du
monde et ma journée il y a que la pub
qui a cette capacité
cette richesse même économique il n'y a
pas une autre média qui a l'argent de la
pub parfois tu prétends faire de l'art
non plus du journalisme et de là et tu
dis effectivement en parlant de la
double page des sexes par exemple tu dis
c'est plus c'est plus une double page de
pub c'est de l'art tu dis l'arme
scandalises plus aujourd'hui il n'y a
que la pub qui peut encore scandaliser
j'ai remarqué ça d'ailleurs c'est
58 photos de sexe
interfusées refusé dans le monde entier
dans tous les journaux à part libération
qui d'ailleurs a vendu 45000 copies en
plus ce jour-là ça signifie que les gens
veulent bien regarder ces choses
et m'a été accepté à la Biennale de
Venise qui est fait une exposition d'art
j'ai dit c'est drôle que les journaux
acceptent pas ça mais l'art accepte
alors au fond
tu vis bien tu es sûrement le
photographe le mieux payé du monde
est-ce que tu crois pas quand même au
fond sérieusement quand tu es tout seul
chez toi dans ta propriété avec ta femme
tes enfants t'occupes de tes vignes tes
oliviers tes chevaux des choses saines
naturelles simples est-ce que tu crois
pas que tout ça c'est quand même
beaucoup pour vendre des pull-over
regardez les peines de renaissance
il s'exprimait c'est quoi qui s'exprimer
c'est très important il y a beaucoup et
moi je suis je crois que je suis
un grand champ un grand privilège de
pouvoir m'exprimer et je fais ce que je
veux j'accepte pas monsieur Palmer et
qui me disent que je dois faire que tu
es un sous homme
est-ce que vous crois pas quand même que
vous êtes allé un peu loin tous les deux
là dans l'histoire non
Luciano et toi vous êtes allés un petit
peu loin ça dépend de point de vue
qu'est-ce que c'est loin et ça dépendent
quelqu'un qui voit très court besoin de
lunettes on a trop loin oui mais
peut-être non parce que on a par exemple
plus que 316 universitaires fait dans
les universités du monde qui parle de
notre campagne de ma communication dans
tous les langues coréennes
espagnoles chinois c'est incroyable j'ai
pas envie de faire une campagne de pub
pour Benetton montrant les les quatre
ministres néophésistes en Italie ça
donne pas envie folklore ça c'est du
folklore dans le monde entier dans
chaque régime tu vois pas que c'est
grave
ma liste et ça on dit rien dans certains
pays je crois tout ça c'est un peu vieux
analysé droit et gauche une certaine
façon il faut je crois il faut être plus
moderne que ça ces inquiétez pas
l'arrivée des 4 ministres néo fascistes
en Italie mais c'est pas les quatre
ministres qui m'inquiète
parce que ça c'est du frocurs qu'on
connaissait qu'est-ce qu'ils font
mais c'est pas les noms fascisme être
humain qui me fait peur parce que ça
plus ou moins on peut contrôler mais ce
qui me fait peur c'est la dictature de
la télé
et la nouvelle les nouveaux fascisme va
pas arriver à bien noir mais il va
arriver sous forme de télévision ça
c'est la vraie dictature donc il faut
plus savoir peur de Berlusconi que de
Mussolini aujourd'hui
je déteste la télé tu regardes jamais la
télé
j'ai des concubines je voyage beaucoup
dans les hôtels cette elle est là
différents formats
et on fait ça on change
et entre temps que les gens regardent la
télé on peut faire beaucoup d'autres
choses quel est ton prochain client
après Benetton
je crois je vais travailler pour la télé
ah bon
la même façon je déteste la pub et je
suis réussi à la
à la retourner un petit peu on peut
commencer à le faire avec la télé
maintenant
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu